adrian hauser is doing adrian hauser
things he's a sinker ball guy he likes
to get the ball on the ground
last time out against these guys he had
19 ground balls
rymel tapia to lead it off against
adrian hauser this is fought off into
left field for another
opposite field base hit rocky's center
fielder up to 323 with the batting
average
jonathan with a couple of hits yesterday
knocked in a run
and he takes off and it's a straight
steal
and a low throw and he has another
stolen base
and this is hit up the middle base hit
and that's going to bring rymel home
easily he'll score standing up
two hitters in one nothing colorado
that's a good start
i'm not gonna lie there was times when i
was pitching i would ask the grounds
crew to soak in front of the plate
because i wanted that ball not to bounce
so high right when that's hit you just
knew was going to rock it through the
infield not hit that hard but
early in the game you it's hard to know
how the turf is going to play
15 start for antonio senzatella and
remember he had the groin injury in
early may and he missed a start he was
on the injured list since he's come back
from that four to one strikeout to walk
ratio
colton wong who will lead things off for
the crew
lined into right bases for
long big turn around first he's gonna
try the throw from blackman
no no tag safe at second colt wong
brings up christian yelage in an rbi
opportunity
nick there's a line drive base hitting
the right
colten long is going to be waved around
third here's the throw from
blackman it's offline 1-1 game
waiting for his pitch got something out
over the dish
went with it and what you're seeing is
he's willing to go opposite field he's
willing to pull the off speed pitches
that's a great sign with approach
long getting his steps in early
[Music]
coming around to score two outs in a
game tied at one a piece
tyrone tanner is the battle
ground ball towards the middle will
sneak through a base hit
yelich is going to come around and score
adamus to third the brewers take the
lead
throwing more fastballs up in the zone
rather than down in the zone but
i couldn't get it out in time before
tyrone taylor t baby
shooting the ball through the middle
yelich the gazelle that he is
scores easily so 2-1 brewers and here's
dazza who's
one for one with a single
way inside so dazzo with one out goes to
first second walk allowed by hauser
bring up charlie curly struck out
swinging his first time
uh-oh could be two wong adonis
it is two as we go to the top of the
fourth inning trevor's story to lead off
for the rockies
hauser at 45 pitches
hopefully that got the elbow guard
the guy that hauser will undoubtedly pay
some attention to
trevor one of the top base steelers in
the national league 13 and he's been
caught four times and there he goes
hauser didn't pay any attention to him
pitch comes in for a strike and story
steals the base standing
hit battery in a walk that's how the
rockies have put together this threat
rocky's trailing 2-1 first and third one
out oh one
and this is to center field base hit got
enough on it tied up the ball game story
trots home
crowned to second how often do we say
get the ball in play and when kesten
puts the ball in play typically good
things happen
over one with a strikeout
and right on cue basic to left for
casting gila
gets the offense going lead off man off
for the second time in four innings
against senzatella
the brewers have two runners on and
hauser coming up
hauser no surprise square in the bunt
here and he bunts it to the first
baseman crone who bobbles it the throw
to third
goes up the line and hits the tarp here
is going to score
pina's being waved around third he's
headed for a home here's the throw
and it's going to be in time hauser goes
all the way to third on the play
pina is still down at the plate a little
slow to get up
great punt by adrian hauser he got down
in there a lot of times that's a tough
place to be
clanker on the glove lost his footing
that might be some of the calibrating
you're talking about
throws it away at third everyone's
coming around manny pena
hey he got that extra gear last night
it's still locked in there i guess
feeling froggy
now we can get trevor to put a good
swing in rockies
get back into a tie or the lead if
possible
and this ball is hitting the air deep
center field way back
and gone i think trevor was off balance
when he finished the swing he's still so
strong just hit it out
and he gives the rockies a 4-3 lead
his ninth of the year a 3-2
bomb from trevor's story
so one away for garcia
garcia with a base hit back in the fifth
inning
garcia down the left field line it is
gone we're tied
you could hang sunday's laundry on that
line drive from avi garcia his 14th home
run
of the season
it's carlos cestebas on for colorado tim
carlos estevez so a walk in the hip
battery see if the brewers can take
advantage of the freebies
he does buck it's perfect estevez
no throw base is loaded
and omar narvaez coming to the plate
swinging a flag ball into center that's
plenty deep robertson back to tag
dazza makes the catch robertson is gonna
score
all runners tagging safe at second
peterson brewers take a 5-4 lead
and everybody moves up luis urias who
has come to the plate with somebody on
base
every inning
up the middle basement penis in
peterson's in big time insurance urease
fired up christian yellench is going to
be the
batter now against the left-handed
offerings of ben
bowden and yellows
to right deep black men
his fifth of the year
what a jump right there by adamus and
yelich
after that blast first pitch
down the left field line the brewers are
going to get another one
garcia scores with ease william thomas
cruises into second
as he trades places with avi garcia
will go to their bullpen again
right-hander miguel
sanchez is going to take them out for a
third time for craig council
tapper back to sanchez he's got it runs
halfway to first ball game over brewers
have won
two straight against the rockies just a
well-played game
by the brewers six run bottom of the
eighth inning that's the difference in
this one
10-4 the final